good morning John this video is going to
be purely instructional because your
YouTube experience could be better if
you knew some YouTube secrets for
example I just flash some text on the
screen but you couldn't read it because
it was only there for one frame but what
are you gonna do you're gonna go back
and then try to pause at the exact right
second no you're not instead you're
gonna watch this video which has 18 tips
for how to use YouTube better including
how to find that text first though let's
talk about subscriptions if you're
logged into YouTube and you go to
youtube.com you will find a page of
content that YouTube has decided that
you probably will want to watch it will
probably keep you on the second it will
not be a feed of videos that you control
the only way to get to that is to click
on this little weird icon at the top and
go to subscriptions also another icon is
your history so you can see videos you
recently watch and your watch later
playlist which is a wonderful thing
because often you see a video that you
want to watch but you don't have time to
watch at that exact moment every YouTube
video has a little clock if you hover
over it you can click that it adds to
your watch later playlist then you can
click on that either on your desktop or
on your phone whenever you want and
watch those videos the majority of
nerdfighters who answered the
nerdfighteria census get their YouTube
videos from the subscriptions feed and
that is wonderful for us because it's
the only page on YouTube where you can
go and actually make sure you're seeing
all the content your favorite creators
are making but the subscription page if
you got a lot of subscriptions like I do
can be a bit of the firehose it makes it
easier to miss content from the people I
never want to miss stuff from which is
why for certain channels I have
notifications turned on it's a little
bell thing you click on it and decide
how you want to get the notification you
can also do this from your subscription
manager page you can see all the people
you're subscribed to maybe take out the
ones that you're not watching so much
anymore and for the ones you never want
to miss a video from you can turn on
notifications you can also set up
notifications on your phone the little
bell on a channel page you can get push
notifications every time a new video
gets uploaded and you can join that
coveted group the notification squad if
you've ever seen that comment your
subscription feed is actually easier to
find on mobile it's one of the big
buttons at the top and now that some
youtubers including us have the ability
to post community posts that aren't
videos but will show up in your mobile
subscription feed you can decide whether
or not you want to see those community
posts for now I'd suggest turning that
on trying it out because we're going to
be messing around with it some in the
coming weeks and this is all fine and
good when you're on your phone or on
your computer but what about if you want
to be on the big screen well if you have
any kind of smart enabled television
that's sharing a Wi-Fi connection
your phone or your computer a little
icon will show up and you can click it
and send your YouTube straight to your
TV and if you're on your phone while
you're watching the video you can queue
up the next video and the next video and
then it's great it's freaking it works
like a dream
YouTube has its problems this is not one
of them I use it all the time now
finally it back to desktop to talk about
hotkeys now because of a weird
confluence of things it's not really
worth talking about sometimes if you
press the spacebar it will pause the
video sometimes it will jump down at a
comet box which will be extremely
frustrating because then you have to
scroll up and then press pause and
you're like why didn't the spacebar just
work but if you push the K key it will
always pause the video L will advance 10
seconds and J will go back 10 seconds
these keys being used for this purpose
is actually a holdover from old video
editing software and a lot of people
think that it's annoying and weird and
like it doesn't make any sense that it's
those particular keys but I actually
kind of love and there are a bunch of
other hotkeys M will mute the video the
up and down arrows will make the volume
go up and down the left and right areas
will advance and reverse the video 5
seconds numbers on your keyboard will
advance the video to that point in the
video so if you like hit 6 it'll go to
60% of the way through the video if you
hit 0 it will go back to the beginning
the greater than or less than Keys will
speed up or slow down the video and
finally the period and comma will
advance and reverse one frame at a time
allowing you finally to catch that weird
one frame of text that the Creator
decided to put on the screen just to
mess with you if you're on your TV or
phone though I got I got nothing for you
just got a pause and unpause real quick
if anybody else has any tips or tricks
for how they use YouTube's most
efficiently I really want to see those
in the comments John I'll see you on
Tuesday